cela dit la journée de demain sera sans
doute bien pénible pour près de 400
mille lycéens qui vont affronter les
premières épreuves du bac
comme le veut la tradition c'est la
philosophie qui ouvre le programme des
réjouissances
alors en guise de conseils de dernière
minute aux candidats anne rongère se
livre à un exercice que la morale
réprouve
elle va nous dévoiler quelques recettes
de triche oui vous avez bien entendu de
triche des recettes tirées des manuels à
pertinents rédigé par un jeune nantais
qui n'a pas froid aux yeux
désiré audric 20 ans c'est parce qu'ils
voulaient consacrer plus de temps au
tennis qu'il a mis au point sa méthode
en vain le son pour tricher aux examens
avec ses petits camarades de classe il a
sélectionné pour nous ces quelques
conseils que la morale réprouve
complètement dépassés les més darche
de même d'ailleurs que les coups d'oeil
furtifs
le reste se passe de commentaires
vous prenez une gratte à laquelle vous
accrocher un élastique par
l'intermédiaire d'une épingle à nourrice
long si les melons du bas jusqu'en haut
de l'épaule je triche pour en fait parce
que j'aime bien fait faire autre chose
que travailler mes examens quand je vois
arriver les sujets comme celui qu'on a
qu'on a montré des sujets complètement
stupide où il suffit juste de recracher
de cours à ce moment-là bon ben qu'est
ce que je fais moi je veux pas passer
cinq ou six heures à travailler ça ce
que je fais c'est que j'ai mes cours que
j'amène directement alors que la
personne qui a qui a travaillé pour
préparer l'examen intellectuellement
d'envoi tir absolument rien qu'est-ce
que vous conseilleriez un jeune qui
débute jeunes qui débutent conseillerais
de bosser pourquoi mais non en fait
c'est un gag ne lui conseillerais de
démarrer avec des méthodes très simple
et très sûr est ce qu'il ya des cas
désespérés de gens qui n'arriveront
jamais à tricher wave ou l'éditeur
n'arriviez pas à tricher parce que vous
rugissiez servez vous même ne vous
inquiétez pas vous n'êtes pas les seuls
dans ce cas là il ya deux ans et qui a
une bonne partie des gens qui ont
travaillé durant leur scolarité parce
qu'il n'arrivait pas à pompe et
généralement quand on travaille c'est
qu'on sait pas pompé l'éditeur de désiré
audrix est à l'amour au entre suicide
mode d'emploi est commencée serve à
réformer en vain le sont ils assument
ils disent dans cet ouvrage nous sommes
pour les enfants qui s'aiment pour les
prisonniers qui s'évade et pour les
banques qui brûle et bien comment
tricher aux examens s'inscrit de manière
peut-être moins dramatique mais à tout à
fait dans cette filiation
quelles sont les limites de la triche je
pense qu'il y en a pas il ya toujours
une méthode pour répondre à une
situation donnée
[Musique]